mais
familles monoparentales c'est dramatique
les étudiants c'est pareil c'est très
difficile les restaurants universitaires
sont fermées donc l'élargît la
caractéristique c'est vraiment
l'élargissement de la population dans le
besoin à trois poulets les bars les
restaurants tout le monde donnait un
café une boisseron tout le monde est là
en fait si personne ne donne rien faute
et permet donc nous on s'est dit on va
peut être essayer de donner pendant une
période de confinement et jusqu'à fin
décembre apparemment on va pouvoir
continuer à distribuer des boissons
chaudes comme ça en plus de la
restauration